plenty of speculation dolphins would
trade out of the sixth overall slot in
the draft
especially with both quarterback mac
jones and
justin fields slipping instead the
dolphins use the pick and they take
alabama receiver not devonte smith
they take jalen waddle so anyone who
placed that bet on waddle being the
first alabama receiver taken
over smith congratulations you win there
was a belief that the dolphins actually
would have taken
waddle before jamar chase if they had a
chance to choose between the two
it's academic because chase went number
five but waddle very likely
the first receiver on miami's board they
get him
over devonta smith it won't be long
before smith goes
for now though jaylen waddle alabama
receiver all of a sudden the crimson
tide a receiver factory
another first rounder in waddle and
another one to come
in devonta smith hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports